amine elias professeur d'histoire et de
sciences politiques immédiates bonjour
et merci être en direct avec nous sur rt
france elle revient de dire un
déconfinement progressif en quatre
phases pendant plus d'un mois c'est la
bonne stratégie selon vous je pense que
l'ensemble nous avons besoin liban deux
en même temps d un régime strict de
confinement parce que quand vous l'avez
déjà dit dans votre introduction les
hôpitaux et sont dans un état ils sont
développés et le corps soignant il est
débordé alors on a besoin toujours de
2,2 ce qu'on filme en stick mais en même
temps il faut il faut trouver des
mesures pourrait graduellement sortir
sortir le pays de ce confinement mais de
façon graduelle bien sûr parce que
toujours la situation sanitaire au liban
elle est toujours très très technique
alors les conséquences du confinement
était désastreuse pour les libanais d'un
point de vue économique et de nombreuses
manifestations ont eu lieu dans le nord
du pays et à tripoli n'a vraiment pour
demander le retrait de ces mesures
c'est un supplice mans va apaiser les
tensions entre la population et
dirigeants selon vous je pense que les
protestations contre le gouvernement au
liban s'est passé comment lier au
confinement
bien sûr il faut reconnaître que le fait
qu' il a beaucoup des gens au liban qui
ont besoin de sortir de leur de chez eux
pour aller travailler
et comme on le dit pour pouvoir mettre
du pain sur la table et ils doivent
travailler d'une façon journalière
convenant pas des dvd des salaires
mensuels est tout cela ils doivent
travailler de façon jeune arrière pour
pouvoir manger le soir
malheureusement ça c'est le cas au liban
et ce qui aggrave cette situation c'est
la crise économique financière et
politique aiguë que les bons côtés il ya
presque un mois et quelques mois un an
et quelques mois c'est à dire plus de 15
mois et ça c'est cette crise économique
financière des politiques qui est à la
base de ces protestations
c'est pas seulement le confinement le
confinement c'est on a besoin comme tous
les pays et toutes les sociétés qui se
confient parce que il faut il faut c'est
un certain c'est une étudiant et
épidémies il a des mots il ya des gens
et qu'ils trouvent pas d déplaceront
hôpitaux alors on a besoin notamment au
niveau après après les vacances de noël
et de fin d'année les hôpitaux et le
corps swan a été totalement débordée et
vraiment nous avons craignais que de
vivre le même scénario et italiens et
espagnols espagnols manuel
heureusement heureusement jusqu'à
l'heure on a évité ce ce scénario
catastrophique mais il faut reconnaître
que la situation sanitaire au liban
allez allez allez allez les critiques et
les hôpitaux sur les indicateurs et
quitter biologique et comme le nombre de
lits état de préparation des hôpitaux
taux de mortalité autour de cas positifs
concernant au nombre de tests faits et
sont toujours éprise alarmants sont très
élevés alors on a besoin de se confirmer
on a besoin d'un des conflits
qu'advienne ça c'est sûr mais la cause
qui est derrière les protestations
populaires notamment à tripoli
c'est la crise économique politique et
financier et justement où en est-on delà
de la crise politique qu'est ce qui
bloque jusqu'à aujourd'hui pour la
formation d'un nouveau gouvernement
alors je pense qu'il ya deux dimensions
il est à la dimension extérieure et vous
savez maintenant le liban il est un
malheureusement il est une arène où des
forces régionales et internationales
ce se bat ça c'est un constat de fait et
en même temps les libanais ne sont pas
d'accord entre eux les présidents et les
rides les vannes et qui sont conformes
ne sont pas d'accord entre eux sur
comment mener une politique pour faire
sortir le pays de cette crise très aigu
ne sont pas d'accord et ils parient que
le disons le la formule malheureusement
qui se fait rudement c'est une formule
qui établit ailleurs qu' imposer sur les
leaders libanais leur cette formule
disons cette solution n'est pas n'est
pas bien et jusqu'à jusqu'à l'heure il
paraît qu'elle n'est pas elle n'est pas
qui ça faisait justement à l'ordre
on compte toujours sur la liste hâtive
du du président français mais même accro
peut-être que dans le mois venant se
défend dur en février
peut-être vidéo qu'il y aura quelques
changements au niveau de la dinde et
bûche mans disons positif de cette crise
politique
on espère on espère merci beaucoup en
tout cas monsieur merci à vous monsieur
elias d'avoir à me les liens d'avoir été
en direct avec nous sur rt franges en
cause est professeur d'histoire et de
sciences politiques analyste également
merci